even right now you see this is why we
need a stimulus check this is why the a
plan that Andrew yang talked about is
effective we can't afford to pay people
thousand dollars a month we can't afford
to pay people two thousand dollars a
month if we're spending trillions on a
military why can't we spend money on
spending and sending checks to people
yeah but yeah we can bail out these big
companies you know the whole concept of
our soldier no - but yeah the idea is to
wrongs make right but they don't and and
we couldn't the bailout summer a mistake
I mean just because we made the mistake
of bailing out the banks in o8 doesn't
mean that we should repeat the mistake
by bailing out the airlines or the
hotel's
uh and just because we made the mistake
of bailing out Wall Street doesn't mean
we compound the mistake by bailing out
Main Street why they do bail out nobody
why do we be a lot like why do we bail
out the too big to fail what is this
well because obviously there's two
reasons one is the politics of it you
know from the day they're gonna be
industries that get bailed out are gonna
recycle some of the bailout money and
line the pockets of the politicians that
voted to bail them out right I mean
that's a quid pro quo that's going to
happen but also when it comes to
economics right you have the scene and
you have the unseen the effects and when
a government bails out a business the
immediate benefits to those who receive
the bailouts are there the company is
there the jobs are saved and so and the
people who benefit from the bailout they
are known and and they will vote for you
the but what you don't see are the
negative consequences that are widely
dispersed throughout the economy where
there's no political constituency for
that but let's take one of these
industries that get bailed out rather
it's Airlines right let's say we didn't
bail out airlines or you know any hotels
or any these companies the way the
politicians want to present it is that
if we didn't bail out these industries
they would disappear like oh we need
airlines
we need hotels we can't just let these
countries go Bank these industries go
bankrupt how will we get around right
see that's the lie of the bailout if the
government didn't bail
the companies they would go through a
normal bankruptcy during a bankruptcy
the companies don't stop operating right
they continue to operate what happens is
they don't have to pay their debts
anymore which is why they're in
bankruptcy because of all the money they
borrowed but they go through a
bankruptcy and who gets wiped out the
common stockholders the unsecured
creditors there are investors who lose
but the businesses to the extent that
they have value survive and new owners
come in and more importantly they're
going to be more responsible than the
owners who failed and the companies are
not going to have all the debt the debt
gets wiped out so now that the
businesses no longer have all the debt
they can be more efficient they can
offer a more competitive product they
can lower prices maybe they can pay
better wages because they're not
hampered with all this debt instead
we're keeping these companies alive by
loading up with even more debt so
they're gonna be even less efficient and
some companies need to shrink you know
that the government is saying we can't
we have to make sure that companies
don't fire any workers why what if they
need to fire workers what if they have
too many workers what that's why they're
not profitable because they have to
downsize their workforce to make the
business competitive and reflect the
free market demand for the products
they're making or the services they're
providing if we keep payrolls bloated
that is a waste of Labor resources we're
squatting those resources we need to
free up that labor to go work someplace
else where the market would direct it
but now we're creating these zombie
companies that are Ward's of the state
and the cost to society of subsidizing
these businesses far exceeds the
benefits to the people who are being
bailed out but again that's the unseen
consequence of government interference
let the free market function and we will
have an optimal allocation of resources
and we will all collectively benefit
from a higher standard of living but we
have the government interfering and
diverting resources from where the
market wants them to where the politics
demand everybody suffers because we have
a
or quality of living a lower standard of
living because we're increasing
production costs and making the economy
less efficient so let's just say we were
to make that adjustment let's say we are
open to it let's say we get somebody
that's strong enough they can present
that to the American people and let's
just say he can convince 51% of people
to say I'm with it I'm with it let's go
through this process of allowing the
too-big-to-fail to fail let's let's go
through the process of you know me going
back to maybe I can do a hundred percent
financing on home maybe it goes to sixty
percent financing on home if you don't
have 40 percent of down payment on the
house
you probably shouldn't own house you
probably should run out let's just say
we go through Malik who benefits right
who benefits from government policy to
guarantee mortgages it's actually not
the person who's buying the house it's
the person who has a house to sell
because by guaranteeing mortgages the
government is helping to prop up real
estate prices if there was no government
guarantee mortgages right if individuals
had to convince the bank to loan the
money based on their own credit quality
their own ability to repay the banks
would not be willing to loan as much
money and they would want more
collateral they wouldn't give you a
mortgage with 3% down or 5% down they
would want 20 25 percent out right and
so if that happened real estate prices
would collapse right so people would
still be able to buy houses they just
wouldn't have to borrow nearly as much
money to do it because the price would
be lower so maybe you can't afford a 20%
down payment when the house you want to
buy as 300,000 but if the house drops to
a hundred thousand you could afford to
pay 20% right you won't have all this
debt the beneficiary of the policy is
the guy who already owns the house who
wants to sell it he can sell it for a
much higher price if the government's
going to guarantee the mortgage of the
buyer but then you have a bubble you
have a phony real estate market I want
to have a real real estate market that
reflects mark the free market not
government subsidies because the
government now has to keep this this
whole pyramid going with more and more
debt but yet it is
going to be a very impossible you know
political battle because right now right
the Republicans have already signed on
to socialism they have basically agreed
with the Democrats that we need big
government right and and it is it's a
logical thing right if they see the
position that the Republicans have is
inconsistent logically the Republicans
are saying during good times the profits
should be privatized
but during bad times we need to
socialize the losses so we we need to
have low taxes and limited government
when times are good but when times are
bad we need massive government and we
have to bail out everybody even the rich
that doesn't make any sense at least the
Democrats can have a logically
consistent though flawed argument we
need big government all the time if we
need big government during bad times we
need big government during good times if
we're gonna socialize the losses
let's socialize the profits right that's
a consistent argument that I think is
going to win which is why I think that
Trump is gonna be a one-term ER because
I don't think he can out promised Biden
or whoever is the at the top of the
Democratic ticket when it's a battle
between two Democrats that never
connects one ways by you worsening you
don't think Trump beats Biden no and I
thought Trump was gonna be Clinton a
very few people did at the time because
the reason I thought that Trump could be
Clinton is because Trump was telling the
truth about how lousy the economy was
and he was promising a real solution now
he's gonna try to perpetuate the same
lie that didn't work for Hillary
although now he's gonna try to blame the
problem on the coronavirus uh
and maybe that strategy will work I mean
I actually believe Biden is gonna be
Trump but at this point look I don't
think the Democrats because the election
is going to be decided over who is gonna
give out the most free stuff and I think
the Democrats win that argument now what
what's going to happen is when we have a
complete collapse of the economy if we
have hyperinflation or complete
implosion and there is massive poverty
inflation is so bad that they have price
controls and the minute they have price
controls you have shortages you have
black markets I mean it's going to be a
complete disaster then
we can have a real campaign between do
we go all in on socialism is this how
are we so broke are we destitute are we
having this misery and poverty right is
it because of too much capitalism and
too much greed right or is it because of
too much government too much central
planning is it the bureaucrats and
socialism that destroyed the prosperity
that capitalism built or did captain
socialism build with prosperity and in
capitalism destroy it and so do we need
to be a nation of slaves or a nation of
free individuals I mean that's going to
be the real debate between a big
government and freedom and and hopefully
freedom can win that debate I don't know
I mean it's a tough call you know you
but you're on record are you saying
Biden's gonna be Trump I think well I
think Biden will be Trump or if Biden
ends up not being the nominee for some
crazy reason I think whoever is at the
top of the ticket will be Trump but I
mean is it a sure thing no I mean I
think that what's your percentage if you
were to betting money on Las Vegas
what's your percentage if I say I say I
say he's 70 I they 17 80% at least that
it's going to be Biden yeah because
we're still going to be in a recession
in November so you're gonna have a bunch
of people voting during a recession and
you know Trump promised a lot of people
to make their lives better and their
lives are going to be worse and you know
are they going to wasn't expect that
occur Lamar Trump wasn't expecting a
pandemic though but he was gonna lose
even without this we were gonna be in
recession even without the coronavirus
it was already starting the economy was
already rolling over the bubble was
already deflating so yes this may be his
only chance which is a reason why Trump
may be incentivized to keep the shutdown
going longer and longer because to the
extent that everything is still shut
down in November it's easier to blame it
on the virus but let's assume that we
try to restart the economy in May or
June and then we're still in a deep
recession which we will be
by November it will be harder for Trump
to to blame the virus I mean he will I
mean I think before the virus he was
gonna blame the Fed but I think the
voters are just gonna blame Republicans
blame Trump and look they are not gonna
be able to out promise the Democrats
we're gonna have a bidding war over
who's gonna give out the most free stuff
who do you think wins that you know I I
just think when it's when you have two
people promising bigger government the
Democrats win it's not going to be an
argument of less government versus more
governor capitalism versus socialism
Catholic Social and Missouri won the
debate Bernie Sanders is now the
mainstream of both political parties I
mean stuff that the Republicans are
supporting today even Bernie Sanders
would have been too embarrassed to
recommend it six months ago
[Music]